yeah that's why I went to uh touchgrass
this weekend actually after my week uh
two weeks of streaming yeah I went to I
didn't realize uh this was going on
until the weekend actually there was a
Thai Festival in Tokyo and like one of
the biggest festivals okay uh outside of
Thailand yeah Thai culture yeah yeah got
a little piece of home which was
interesting uh so I turn up to this uh I
turned up to this huh my homies okay but
first
thing uh
any place in the world where I literally
did not know what language to speak like
so
English Japanese yeah do I do I speak
English do I speak Japanese do I speak
to I remember like oh so I turned up and
uh within like two hours the fan
recognizes me and we start the
conversation he asks uh if he could take
a picture in Japanese I reply in
Japanese we have a short Japanese
exchange uh then Sydney comes in and uh
she she wants to flex her the little tie
that she knows so she starts speaking to
women Thai she uh she he replies in Thai
speaks back to me in Japanese but then I
I notice we're starting to speak in Thai
so I reply in Thai right and then
another another fan recognizes me start
speaking to me in English so the
conversation just switches to English
and I'm just like this is I feel like
I'm in like that YouTube video where
it's just like polyglot reflects how
many languages they can speak because we
would it was it was so [__] weird
because everyone there was basically
bilingual at least yeah most of them
were like how many of them like actually
Thai
um quite a lot actually yeah so there
were quite a lot of Thai people there
um and it's so most of it was like food
stalls and everything like that uh but
there was one uh so I was I was looking
around to see what's uh what store had
the longest line because I was like I
wanted the best Thai food I'm I miss
home I wanted the I wanted a piece of
the home so I look around and I see one
store had by far the longest line out of
any stall in the entire Festival right
I subconsciously just start lining up
just in case I want to do and so I like
tracked the line and the line's so long
that it kind of like loops around so
it's it's like it's like a line loops
around and it Loops back round again and
I'm like oh what is this line for
it's slime for the [__] garbage
I [__] I [__]
what kind of rancid
I don't know if this is a normal thing
for like Japanese festivals because this
is kind of like the first Festival that
I've been to
um so they don't they they have they
don't have like they don't have like
bins there they have like garbage stalls
where you have the same old you know you
you have the same kind of like station
where you can separate your garbage but
they have an actual like uh they have an
actual stand for that or like it's like
manned yeah it's like man oh yeah man
that must be a [__] show yeah yeah so so
the problem was there's only so many
stores where you could get rid of your
garbage because there were no public
bins yeah of course
um so I don't know if this is normal for
a Japanese festival because I went there
and most of the time uh most of my uh
waiting time was uh waiting to get rid
of the [__] I I kept buying and yeah
unfortunately I was very hungry and I
wanted to go to as many stores as
possible so anytime I bought something I
was like [__] sake I go like I got
like a Thai Noodle in my hand and I
can't I can't put it anywhere no which
uh that's very Japanese yeah which kind
of kind of shows
how dedicated the Japanese culture is to
uh following rules and not littering
because I swear to God if this was in
place because at bare minimum to get rid
of any garbage even if you had like a
single bottle in hand it was like a 15
minute wait
a while
I would just eat the plastic
what I would have done is just like I
would have gone to like the nearest
company or something yeah buy something
get a plastic bag and just hold that
[__] yeah that's what I would have done
yeah and then like once I'm like back at
a station or another company or
something because because it was uh so
[__] frustrating to get rid of just
the simplest thing but at the same time
no one littered I was [__] it I I was
amazed there was not a single like there
was not a single piece of garbage I saw
at this massive Festival which had like
two thousand like yeah because any other
country if they see a line to throw [__]
out people would just be like [__] this
yeah just like stop littering right yeah
let's make a pile yeah yeah I'll start
everyone join in yeah especially when
you're throwing alcohol into that mix as
well which was the biggest like I can't
I can't believe this is actually
happening people are getting drunk in
public and people are actually still
conscious enough to uh throw their [__]
away and wait in line to throw their
[__] away
um but yeah it props up to the Japanese
people are I didn't know this but uh I
went there and uh I didn't know there
were Thai Idols that uh were a thing as
well titles uh titles titles uh so there
was uh you know there was a main stage
where you know different concerts and
different performances uh were going on
and I was like Sydney we got we got it
we got a bear in hand one although why
let's let's watch some let's watch some
time musicians perform and uh we we go
in and they go so next uh next man
coming off is a bkt 48 and I was like
ain't no way this is a [__] thing and
yeah and apparently uh or on steps on
bkt48 I guess the uh I guess uh Bangkok
went uh we want akb48 at home and uh
Bangkok Thailand 48. yeah yeah I think
it's uh just bkt which is like uh
Bangkok yeah Bangkok Thailand uh yeah
Bangkok have their own bkt 40 year and I
found out that basically every doing
research I was like there's no way
there's no way this is real yeah uh it
is real uh apparently there's a Bangkok
sister Idol from akb48 and there's it
there's jkt 48 as well
no way I had I had no idea this was a
thing oh my God and they basically all
do the same songs like it's it's like
they all do the same songs wait so are
they like original all songs are there
like covers from akb48 some of them I
believe some of them are covers and some
of them this is my name oh and I I was
like I was like I hate Idol groups yeah
I I do too but I just love that concept
I'm just like let's just take the city
name condense it down to three letters
and get 48 of them yeah and do that for
every country
are you serious jkt
perhaps
just like what is the [__] point of
having 48 members that's so [__] many
because you get all the choice in the
world to choose who you who your or she
is right yeah so I have basically zero
knowledge about akb48 so I I kind of I
kind of missed uh I kind of missed that
train
oh you're probably better off to be
honest yeah yeah it was so [__] weird
right because obviously this was a Thai
festival and uh you know even though
there are a lot of Thai Idol fans uh I'm
sure uh this Festival was full of just
you know different members uh of uh
people who just wanted to come to the
Thai festival and you just saw the
dichotomy between there were like one or
two hardcore bkt 48 fans that were just
like there was one there was there were
two people that were just like sitting
on each other's shoulders and just like
hardcore you you know you know when you
you know the choreography but you like
go you like they're those guys that just
lean into it yeah yeah yeah it's not
just like they they know like the
choreography they're like oh
[__] uh like it's like they're doing
a full-on exercise they're leaning into
this 100 and then they're just like some
Thai grandmas to be like I don't know
what's going on right now but I'm going
to clap I'm going to class that's the
karaoke assistant should I go up on
stage
Corrections
Bangkok all right apologies